with the world moving towards the next
generation of computer hardware the
softer side of things still has a lot
left to discover
with the majority of laptops coming with
windows pre installed many users are
devoid of the linux operating system
experience which is more resource
friendly than the mainstream operating
systems
it can be attributed to the difficulty
people used to face when installing a
new operating system like linux in the
old days
however a lot of these issues are fixed
nowadays thanks to the big names like
debian and ubuntu who have been
instrumental in making linux based
operating systems as user friendly as
possible but which one of them is better
for you
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today as we answer this question
for you
we start by learning about the operating
systems from a layman's perspective and
uncovering the basic offerings of both
entities
next we cover the unique features of
both ubuntu and debian and how they
stack up against each other and other
industry counterparts
moving on we take a look at some
pointers before installing each of these
operating systems and the respective
download links
finally we compare the contrasting
features of both ubuntu and debian and
infer the kind of users each os caters
to
so let's start by learning about ubuntu
and debian in general
ubuntu is an open source free linux
distribution
it is an operating system for cloud
computing in accordance with support
with openstack ubuntu is developed by
the canonical community and it is freely
available
also canonical limited is responsible
for the funding of ubuntu
basically ubuntu is released every 6
months free support is available for 9
months after every release and long term
support which are the ltes is released
every 2 years
the first release of ubuntu was in
october 2004.
you must have heard about ubuntu no
matter what it is the most popular linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course ubuntu
managed to simplify the linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive linux distributions available
right now
every new release is more polished and
comes loaded with new features and
improvements
thanks to its huge user base a number of
software vendors have made the
applications compatible with ubuntu
while the catalog may not be as
extensive as windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open source alternatives to major
proprietary software
by lacking some polish and overall
feature set most alternatives are enough
to get the job done for majority of the
users the never-ending community support
also helps in troubleshooting should
things go wrong at any point in time
the default desktop environment in
ubuntu is gnome or a unity
the unity is a modern desktop
environment with a powerful search tool
for finding all your applications and
documents with its base setup as no
it integrates well with common
applications such as audio players video
players and social media there are a few
other desktop environments for ubuntu as
well with unity as its flagship
environment
debian on the other hand is a free
operating system for your computer which
started in 1996 and is maintained by
global contributors
if the operating system a set of basic
programs and utilities that make your
computer run its core is the kernel the
kernel is the most fundamental program
on the computer debian uses the linux
kernel a completely free piece of
software which was started by linus
strowballs and supported by thousands of
programmers worldwide
a large part of the basic tools that
fill out the operating system come from
the gnu project and those rules are free
as well
debian is the mother of linux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good looking distro is
so popular inside the linux developers
community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful ui
later on they found out the power of
debian after using a bunch of
distributions from other developers you
will be surprised to know that almost
all other popular consumer level
digitals are based on debian even ubuntu
it is so stable and feature-rich that
the developers find it easy to build
their distros based on debian rather
than building it from scratch
debian is run and maintained on its
github repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
community-wide feedback and holistic
approach to open source development of
the debian operating system
thanks to this variety of personnel the
source code of debian comprises around
70 different programming and scripting
languages
debian supports all kinds of graphical
environments ranging from full feature
desktop environments to lighter
alternatives and email minimalist window
managers
ubuntu ships with unity desktop by
default but the package manager can
install the gnome environment if needed
while also including cinnamon lxd xfce
kde and mate on the other hand debian
gives you the choice of choosing which
desktop environment you want from the
get-go by providing iso files for each
desktop environment individually
now that we understand where both these
operating systems stand let us take a
look at some of the best features
offered by each of these distributions
ubuntu is the closest thing to a
household name among desktop linux
distributions it is a great distribution
to start with and it's even a great
distribution to keep using after you're
more experienced if you're happy with it
it is user friendly in a lot of ways it
provides a simple desktop has an easy
installer and provides a checkbox during
the installation process that would
automatically install flash plugins and
various codecs that you will need for
multimedia support there's an additional
drivers tool that will detect closed
source or proprietary drivers that might
be necessary to get all your hardware
working and easily install them for you
ubuntu is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform
still canonical is responsible for
delivering six monthly milestone
releases and regular lts releases from
enterprise production use
enterprises can count on canonical to
support secure and manage ubuntu
infrastructure and devices
with more than 500 employees in over 39
countries the company underpins the
critical infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of ubuntu users
around the world
unity desktop was originally developed
by canonical and introduced earlier for
netbook computers with ubuntu 10.10 then
it went down to be the default desktop
environment for ubuntu
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by nome
however it has made a comeback after
ubuntu 18.04
while being completely stable the hud
and global menu hold up just fine with
major applications such as libreoffice
thunderbird and other web browsers
that means that the unity desktop works
as it is supposed to while making you
more productive but some desktop
environments have a steep learning curve
unity is very intuitive for new users in
spite of deviating from the traditional
start menu format that the you windows
users are generally accustomed to
the calamaris installer is a framework
by design it is very customizable in
order to satisfy a wide variety of needs
and use cases calamaris aims to be easy
usable beautiful pragmatic and more
importantly distribution agnostic
calamaris includes an advanced
partitioning feature as well which
supports for both manual and automated
partitioning operations it is the first
installer with an automated replace
partition option which makes it easy to
reuse a partition over and over for
distribution testing
coming to debian it is a community
distribution through and through
it's governed by a board of elected
developers it has its own internal
structure and laws and just about
everyone working on it is a volunteer
making it completely community driven
it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world
this form of development ensures
continuity if one of the developers
decides to stop working on the project
another developer might come in and take
place and keep the project going on
it is completely free of centralized
control and this is also one of the
reasons for an undecided stable release
cycle
debian sid is the permanently unstable
development version of debian it's where
the latest versions of programs are
being considered for inclusion in the
debian release cycle are uploaded and
tested
because it has no official install media
and the few net boot images that are
built often don't work even people who
are willing to risk using a development
version may have trouble installing it
however it still remains the best place
to test new features that have not yet
made their way onto the stable branch
debian has only free and open source
software in its repositories this is
mostly ample for our users
except for users who use hardware that
only has proprietary drivers these
repositories work well in most cases
it is possible to add other reports as
well that have propriety software if
that is the requirement
debian standard version is very stable
as software and libraries in it go
through rigorous testing the stability
makes debian a perfect server os and
it's also the same reason why average
users shy away from using debian as
their primary os on desktop
this is also one of the reasons why many
developers use debian as a base for
their derivative one of which is also
ubuntu
now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get the downloadable images
when it comes to ubuntu ubuntu has
dropped the support for 32-bit systems
currently it supports only 64-bit
devices and arm devices
installation is easy with the calamaris
framework coming into iso pre-default
and the latest iso can be downloaded
from the link being shown on the screen
right now
in the case of debian the support for
multiple range of devices is still
present
that can also include 32-bit systems and
other smaller devices which are not
modern
even though it does not use the
calamaris installer even downloading the
iso file can be a bit hectic for newer
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult because of which we have
mentioned the link on the screen below
where you can get the latest iso
depending on which desktop environment
you choose to go with
with the installation out of the way
let's take a direct comparison of the
features between both ubuntu and debian
debian is a community driven open source
linux distribution and is primarily
aimed to be robust capable and most
importantly free on the other hand
ubuntu is also an free and open source
like debian but it's backed up and
developed by a canonical which is a
corporate company
debian and ubuntu are both fundamentally
fast regarding performance
as debian comes bare minimum and is not
bundled or pre-packed with additional
software and features it makes it super
fast and lightweight at least when
compared with ubuntu directly
both ubuntu and debian use the same apt
software packaging management system but
provide a different software repository
debian is more like promoting freedom of
choosing free software thus it does not
include any proprietary software by
default
you can always install the paid versions
but you have to enable it manually
ubuntu focuses on usability including
all the software including free paid
open source closed source etc ubuntu
also introduced a universal package
management system called snap it will be
used across distros and thus prevent
more distro based software
fragmentations
as the debian distro does not contain
any proprietary blobs there might be
some problems with drivers and firmware
that means navient lacks some of the
essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other page software
on the other hand ubuntu does not care
how much whether it's paid free open
source or clone source so it includes as
many drivers and firmware as possible
ubuntu also lets you install and
configure the necessary drivers and
firmware automatically during
installation or afterward
if you are a gamer then you will
probably be concerned with the latest
software drivers and hardware support
while debian can potentially provide
that it is likely that you might end up
breaking your installation as mentioned
before ubuntu supports certain
proprietary packages as well which often
consists of graphic drivers which are
essential to gaming
debian focuses on the open source aspect
of the software
hence it can be a well-known fact that
with gamers ubuntu and some other
distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and hardware support
regarding the audience they cater to
both ubuntu and debian have their pros
and cons
ubuntu is a very good distribution for
amateur users with little to no
experience and if they want to have the
latest versions of packages and
applications at all times on their
systems
it is also for users who do not want a
lot of customizability in spite of unity
being very customizable desktop
environment
it is also perfect for users with newer
hardware since it comes updated with all
the latest graphical devices and their
respective drivers
debian on the other hand is catered
towards a little bit of experienced
users who can fix some minor bugs on
their own or with minimal community
support it also is for users who want to
support an open source approach rather
than an operating system which is devoid
of any contribution from other end and
is primarily backed by a corporation
it also doesn't favor gaming since it
does not guarantee compatibility with
all the newest graphic cards or even
wi-fi cards in some cases
however due to the low memory overhead
debian is very useful for people who are
looking to run home servers or even
corporate environments where running
servers on debian will provide much more
use hope you learned something new today
if you have any doubts regarding the
topic please let us know your queries in
the comment section below and we will
get back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
informative videos like this and thank
you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here